Kinney is with us in San Bernardino hi
Kinney welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up my wife and I sold our
house we're closing Monday and we had
this crazy plan to take the equity out
of our home while the market is like
really bloated here in California and
wait for it we're going to rent our
in-laws house wait for the market to
drop and then buy back in but I didn't
know what to do with our equity in the
meantime maybe you had some advice for
me Wow problem is we don't know when
your market is going to crash enough for
you to be motivated to jump back in
right if it waits 10 years it won't
crash enough to come down to where it is
today which will kind of mess up your
plan well the Lord's plan well in the
Lord's hands anyway know the plan you
had was not the Lord's plan the plan you
had was to cash out at the top of the
market thinking that the market was
going to crash in California that's not
the Lord's plan that was your plan okay
well not blame this on God you're taking
your best shot at something so what I
would do if if if I was sitting where
you're sitting now is I would give
myself a time limit that I was going to
stay out of the market to wait on the
weight on a drop you don't want to wait
indefinitely on a drop because you're
going to get yourself in a real pinch do
you understand what I'm saying yeah this
week it's going to go up so much if it
doesn't drop for 10 you if it doesn't
drop for 10 years it's going to go up so
much that when it does drop it'll just
drop down maybe to where it is now right
so you don't want to stay out of the
market perpetually waiting on a drop
that's a doomsday scenario that you're
playing that won't work mathematically
so I would give myself a time limit I'm
going to say I'm gonna sit on the
sidelines for three years or whatever
you think something like that a number
like that would be you know three years
four years two years something like that
if you're gonna be under five years
which you need to be on this scenario I
think
you're probably don't need to invest the
money because or at least all the money
because you're you know you the stock
market could be down at the time you're
trying to buy so how much money are we
putting how much money is in this and
we're talking about you're in this
equity we're gonna get about a hundred
thousand in equity and then we're going
to add our twenty thousand we have saved
up besides that to it so on and twenty
thousand okay so if you invest that in
mutual funds and let's just say for easy
math that one hundred twenty thousand
made ten percent it made $12,000 ok if
it did that three times over three years
you would make like forty forty five
thousand dollars investing in mutual
funds okay if you did that you say so
however it could go down and your
hundred twenty thousand could turn into
ten or turn into a hundred thousand so
if you're willing to take that kind of a
swing risk with this particular money in
the play that you're making you could
invest some or all of it in some simple
growth stock mutual funds because you've
got a very short window I would use a no
load fund and I'd probably just use what
I personally do when I'm doing stuff
like that is short short term investing
is I just use an S&P 500 it's a simple
like go to Vanguard or somebody like
that and just get an S&P 500 fund a very
easy purchase kind of a no-brainer and
it's gonna do whatever the stock market
does though okay so the stock markets up
a half a percent today that's not bad
you know if you did that every day buy a
great day right this is the dowel
sitting at 26,000 but if Trump decides
to to burp when he's playing with Korea
or Iran or China the thing could go down
right so your hundred and twenty could
be worth a hundred I don't think you
could lose more I I doubt you'd lose
more than twenty or make more than forty
over a three year period of time that
would be my guess if you're willing to
play that kind of a spread on it you're
willing to take that kind of a risk
emotionally fine if you're scared to
death about all that kind of stuff just
Park it in the money market you're gonna
make nothing on it but you're gonna lose
nothing on it
you make 1% you know you may still make
it 12,000 make 1200 bucks or something a
year
so it's not you know basically we're
just parking it it's a glorified shoebox
that's what a money market is these days
so but if you don't want to the risk
that's the way you do it I would not
stay out of that real estate market more
than three years more than four years if
I were doing the plan you're doing so
that I'm afraid that it it might not
correct enough to for your plan to work
out for you